interestingly we have this uh supreme
court case
so
scotus rules police cannot search homes
without warrants in the name of
community caretaking this is unanimous
nine to zero so that's promising even
the liberal justices were like a cop
can't go into your house without a
warrant and take all your guns because
they think you're you're ill or
something
it's a good sign
but it's it's it's crazy to me that the
argument is is getting close to the red
flag a lot of stuff
and a lot of people
i guess right now are like oh of course
they can't have you know they can't
without a warrant but what they've been
actively trying to do is get a warrant
claiming that you're unwell and then
violating your rights yeah
disarming you through a subversive means
and it's like in in i think it's
according to the geneva convention
disarming a population is considered an
act of war wow as it should be i think i
believe that somewhere it's uh and that
either is that or it's carl von
klausowitz but we haven't had a von
klossowitz in a while so you might know
this but what percentage of the time is
a genocide preceded by removing guns
from the general population because i
was able to come up with more than one
example to send to someone i was arguing
with yeah i wouldn't say it's a hundred
percent but it's basically a hundred
percent yeah i mean it's it's
because they are one in the same and
this is how you think about tyranny so
we often think or the the thing is
oftentimes said something like
well if you disarm a population then
then then you will have genocide or then
you'll have some sort of massive
glo you know massive tragedy
horrible authoritarian argument and so
we use it as this argument of like the
one begets the other i don't think
that's the right way to think about it
the rather is the act of
the act of um because that i'm sorry i
don't think it's the right way to think
about it because it creates an
opportunity for someone to say we won't
do it this time you know we won't okay
we'll take away your guns but we won't
genocide you this time like that's
you're essentially
holding on the you're holding your
entirety of your existence and your hope
on the fact that they won't do something
whereas what i would i think the better
way to think about it is the act of
taking the firearms away from somebody
is wrong in the exact same way as it is
to target a population in that way
well one doesn't get the other they are
they fall in the same vein you need to
understand that if the earth is to join
the galactic federation we can't have a
bunch of crazies with guns we're going
to shoot the aliens when they show up so
they got to disarm us for the sake of
the of the galactic federation right um
your condescension is coming through
wow no i'm just being ridiculous
no i'm just kidding there's what it is
it's a bunch of elites
who would lie to the general public to
protect themselves and their family they
would tell you there's no gas shortage
so they can go buy gas before you can
they would tell you that everything's
fine there's tons of toilet paper so
they can buy it before you can they
would
buy a bunch of stock while serving in
congress
and then pass regulations on these
companies which benefit their stock
decisions their trading decisions and
they would come out and say you can't
own weapons because safety now for me
i've got five armed guards around me at
all times paid for by your tax dollars
yeah and we use guns for you we saw this
last year the exact same people that
were arguing to defund the police spent
millions of dollars making sure they had
very armed people protecting their house
and we and and it's like and you can't
look at that and say oh that's funny you
should look at that and go like appalled
by that the the even the people who
voted for what we we do man i mean the
people who watch a show like this
um probably most conservatives we we are
appalled by that but there is a large
faction in this country
of extremely ignorant tribal individuals
who have no idea what's going on um i
posted this on facebook i said what
happened all those people who used to
come in my mentions and just like
promote joe biden and rag about trump
they're all gone
well gone you know why because they
never cared about biden no then because
you what bought guns now you're a bad
now you're a bad conservative man no
back during the election all of these
people i knew who cared nothing for
politics never did all of a sudden we're
like oh by then we had to vote for biden
we must do it
and then biden gets elected and they're
gone they no longer care about trump
they don't care about biden they don't
care about politics now they post about
stupid nonsense and i'm like i thought
what about all those things you were so
what happens is these people now have
voted for a man who is by like every
objective metric failing and i love
these op-eds where they're like biden's
had the best hundred days of any
president ever and i'm like yeah if your
head's in the toilet you're not paying
attention but a lot of people a lot of
these people just walked away anyway
so now things are getting worse
and too many of these people
vote for trash laws and leave us worse
off for it i don't know how you solve
for that
unless like starship troopers or
whatever i don't know uh in order to in
order to vote you must prove or prove
ownership of a firearm
yeah i mean then you'd at least have
skin in the game it's meant to be
facetious but it does get the point
across mandatory gun ownership i mean
you we don't the problem with containing
something a vote like this is not it's
not a very complicated problem it's that
who gets to choose
right this is essentially the question
of all power like thank you who gets to
choose right so if you make it
you know one of the arguments that comes
up is something like
uh we don't want people who are mentally
in
thankfully for the the supreme court
case that you're talking about we don't
want we want to make sure at least to
some extent people of certain mental
issues don't own firearms right we kind
of want to there there's this sort of
it's let's take the question honestly
and look at it that way yes that's true
who gets to choose big question it's it
is an interesting point because i've
brought up several times the second
amendment doesn't say the right to keep
in bear arms should not be infringed
unless you're mentally ill yeah i know
and it is a problem like it is a
legitimate mental problem or you say
like you you were arguing about if you
do the time if you pay your debt to
society you should have your rights
restored
so a good point was made to me though
that the constitution does allow for
rights to be restricted uh after after
or only through due process only through
due process so and mental deficiency i
believe
through due process then all right i
understand that argument that makes
sense to me
yeah so if if you know i own a bunch of
guns
and then there's a claim filed against
my mental health and we go and there's a
legal process
and then after determining i'm unwell
then they come and take everything
that makes sense to me i'm still worried
about it because
mental health is
not
objective
it's an ambiguous category in some ways
it is viewed as an ambiguous category oh
yeah so some guy can just be like i was
looking at ian and he is crazy my
professional experience is that he is
crazy and dangerous dude and then the
judge is like i agree ceases guns anyone
that's got like a medical marijuana card
for stress or any kind of psychological
issue could then be deemed like unwell
and unfit to hold a gun that's cool oh
yeah you can't you can't you can't buy a
gun if you smoke pie right well you're
not supposed to you so can and should
are different
um there is no but there is a question
on the 4473 that asks are you currently
or are you consuming illegal substances
and it's and the 4473 is a federal
document and straight up if you smoke
pot you can't buy it so technically
speaking if you you are committing a
very big crime if you are currently
consuming marijuana or not like smoking
it at the gun shop
i mean but not not technically literally
your federal government literally says
you are committing crime if you consume
these things under biden did it yeah
it's freaking crazy man schedule one
narcotic marijuana that makes no sense
right yeah there's a there's a parallel
that's kind of coming through in in the
world and this is kind of begging the
question but there's the joke who won
the war on drugs weed won the war on
drugs right it's kind of a humor and how
did weed win the war on drugs mass
non-compliance yeah which was is you
could also look at that in a sort of
philosophical sense it was self-reliance
well the government's not going to let
me have my weed so i'm going to get it
myself the government's not going to
allow me to protect my family so i'm
going to figure out myself it's time to
end the war on guns
absolutely yeah but how do you do it i
mean we a whole and for us we're doing
it through culture we're doing it
through going out and doing things we
have our publications and what do we get
for it we get pulled off of newsstands
really yep we've we've had our magazine
anything gun related has been pulled off
of newsstands no one no one talked about
you didn't see a giant new york times
post when google bans gundam wing
because it's got gun in the name you
know they really don't like guns but how
are we being self-reliant here's a good
example if you own a gun store give us a
call we'll stock it in your
on your shelf right there you go if you
own a gun store if you own an ffl
we you get a hold of us you can get a
hold of us through our website and we
will we have a program to stock
our magazines because we've got four
different magazines concealment which is
urban smaller firearms all about safety
concealed carry making sure you're doing
things the right way being good at it um
and then you've got recoil which is the
main magazine this is sort of the big
news gun industry things maybe it's
someone came out with something really
innovative or
you know we there's a there's an
advocate well we did um monster ray we
put yeah
dude so he's you know monster is doing
something great there's uh chris chang
is doing something great um with aap i
go so we are grabbing we have those two
magazines then we have off-grid which is
much more focused on skills survival
um and it has it and and i think of the
the advantage that off-grid has it has a
lot of things about doing
right so it's not just about gear
because a lot of a lot of um
survival
a lot of the negativity that comes from
survivalist groups or preppers is
they're just about buying stuff it's the
classic you know heavily unfit person
with a bunch of stuff is not going to
survive the apocalypse right yeah and
then the last one we have is carnivore
which is all about high-end
field-to-table
consumption meat consumption yep
so i i i uh loathe to think about what's
going to happen to these cities in the
event that there's like an actual
shutdown
the water shuts off
people are going to start dying to
dehydration they'll be drinking blood in
a day
yeah you'll have i mean historically
speaking you'll have a very short period
of very very ugly violence and then
you'll have a very long period of
probable starvation oh you know people
fleeing like crazy in random directions
well and the solution is actually in
itself
and i think the solution to this one is
not just buying a bunch of stuff it's
actually community
it's i mean the term community is thrown
around a lot publicly right now but
the again the antidote to this classic
idea of a guy in a basement with a bunch
of bullets and a bunch of food is that
he's going to die alone why is what is
what is prison it is living in a box for
30 years
you know there's not it's it's taking
your life away life is time so survival
real survival when we're talking about
things like this
is actually 100 based on community
social interaction with people who you
actually trust that you've been a little
you've been you've been you can you can
have them
to protect you from making mistakes that
you would otherwise not know right so
someone who knows water someone who
knows ecology someone who knows hey
don't eat those plants that's a simple
form of it a more complicated one is
you're desperate we know each other we
take care of each other we're not
waiting for the government to come and
save us
it's actually quite remarkable how uh
people in cities mostly but basically
everybody is extremely detached from the
basic requirements of survival yeah i
mean maslov's hierarchy of needs yeah
right it's not it's not an
ultimatum but
people
you take a person in the city you put
them in the woods
it's just not going to go well sure
because they have no reason to be
adapted to the woods if you live in an
urban environment your all life you're
never going to need to adapt the
abilities to do that it's a it's a
luxury you will need to adapt the
abilities it's likely at some point in
your life you will need to understand
basic survival even if you live in a
city it's just that
and they're immediate they don't they
that life has been kind to them to the
extent that they've never been thrust in
a situation like that sure that's
absolutely true but we i still want to
return to the idea like
self-sufficiency
is a good thing
right right so it's not you know when
you have a neighborhood like say you
know you live in a condo and you know
your neighbors it's not a it's not a bad
thing to know your neighbors and being
like oh i know such and such as a
diabetic
and i can help them to i can help take
care of them this way it doesn't mean
you're kicking down their doors and
saying here take the insulin
right but it's good people people don't
realize how brutal it'll get if there's
actual like power outages
or uh like rolling blackouts even let
alone if the water shuts off or the
electricity goes out for a certain
period of time
people people who are diabetic you gotta
refrigerate the insulin that's a huge
problem for just storms going out they
gotta have generators usually to make
sure the fridges keep running but
there's a lot of other things too
people's medications will spoil if
you've got antibiotics in the fridge
they're gone vaccines go bad
very very quickly without electricity
yeah so hey bring it on go to tune
burger let's turn off all the fossil
fuel power plants and then see how long
humans last because they will they will
start tearing each other's throats
throats out as it gets bad
or they'll just build a pipeline and not
tell you about it
pipeline a pipeline yeah you know if you
if you tell people they can't have
something and they need it they'll
figure out a way look one of the big
themes of this is that they're going to
tell you oh no don't go buy this then
they go rush out and buy it sure they're
coming out saying like go the water is
going to rise 20 feet i'll take that
beachfront condo on miami beach how much
is that water's rising no i don't care
about that no sure ammunition prices are
high right now so if you're hoarding
ammunition it's kind of rude but
but the other thing about it too is how
about you just take seriously what you
think you need it's not more panic
buying is a hard thing to define and
panic buying is what people do when they
feel like they're insufficient with what
they have it's interesting i mean
ian bought a ridiculous amount of flour
for two years yes
yeah i was surprised it was available
because i'm
last july that it wasn't you could get
four or maybe four bags of flour why buy
so much flour
you know who knows what's coming in two
months i like to look ahead and rest
easy see that's the thing you know
you're hoarding is it someone being
prepared or is it someone panicking yeah
the the there is a good question to be
said there and
or is it are you just a good businessman
and you know you can buy better in bulk
and you're going to be able to store it
and you are you being proactive after
the apocalypse all the neighbors are
going to be like bread and ian's going
to be like i have the bread and i'm
going to go feed you all and he's going
to like rip it and throw it to people
and they're going to cheer for bullets
bread for water
feed the masses uh i don't think anyone
would trade you bullets for bread they
only need one i'll let them go hunt and
i'll keep them healthy when they don't
understand
they only they only need one oh well
that's a good point you grossly
overestimate the accuracy of most people
that's fair that's fair let's assume
it's point blank uh they don't need any
actually they just need the weapon
you know then most people would just
capitulate just take whatever you want
leave me alone
take my flower take my bread yeah i'm in
fire me but violence is expensive
yeah yeah i mean it's costly to go to go
do violence on someone is expensive
i mean what about apocalypse though it
still is right so let's go let's take
the metaphorical um the metaphorical
post-apocalyptic apocalypse situation
you have your little tribe and they have
their little tribe for you to go attack
their tribe to try to take their stuff
you have to willingly acknowledge that
if you lose it's final yeah right or you
know in order final it's extremely
costly not just that but
if i go to ian and i say ian
make me bread and then ian's like in
exchange for what and i say i'll trade
you something then
ian's skill and value as a human being
contributes to the production of bread
if you just go and take the flour all
right well now you got to make the bread
yeah so there's a there's a cost you
lose out trade is probably safer and
easier for everybody sometimes traders
doesn't work though because
a starving person might not have
anything to trade with
so a lot of times it's the language
barrier fortunately we have that going
for us in the u.s is it's easy to
communicate relatively you know we don't
long-range communications with the power
grid down would be a little bit more
complex like how do you how do you tell
them that you're not a that you're not a
danger without getting close
that that might be a challenge you can
kind of just signal you gotta create a
call
i like ham radios calls yeah bird calls
those words maybe like a bar
yeah yeah yeah we can go back to classic
bird zones i i will lose at every time
they'll just be like why is that man
sounding like a chicken but are we are
we is this paranoia i mean are we just
we're talking about all the stuff we're
seeing the news we're seeing gas prices
and we're like oh it's the end but maybe
enough thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you